every single one of my q and A's is
sponsored by keeps which means we'll
handle from them somewhere in the middle
of the video hello everyone I'm Alana
welcome to my channel and today we are
doing another gaming q a i do Q A's
about basically everything else on my
second Channel this one is all for video
games if you would like to leave a
question for the next q a leave them in
the comments below and ignore
um banjo over here just furiously eating
his own butt he's just he's going at it
and I'm not gonna stop him I'm not one
to kicking Dylan Levine asked is there a
reason you rarely ever do Nintendo first
hour gameplays I was hoping to see
Bayonetta three Metroid dread cubby
forgotten to land and even Legends
Arceus or chaos I still don't know how
to pronounce it this is a great question
because it hadn't even occurred to me
that I was missing those so I did do
Kobe forgotten land I suspect you missed
it but the way that I do my first hour
Let's Plays is a combination of games
I'm okay with playing publicly because
there are some games that I just want to
experience by myself and thus I will
never let's play the more stream and it
just is based on my availability
obviously I've said this a thousand
times before but YouTube is not my job
which means I'm not great at it
I like a lot of the content that I made
I think the podcast I make are all very
good and very informative and I'm proud
of them but they still happen after work
hours and are often publishing at weird
times because they just do what I can
outside of a pretty demanding full-time
job so for Bayonetta 3 metro dread and
Pokemon Legends for all three of those
game releases I wasn't in town I was
just overseas or otherwise unavailable
that's it for Bayonetta 3 I was
definitely in Vegas for magic 30 for
Pokemon Arceus I was in
um Canada I was in
um Whistler which was also awesome I
don't remember where I was at Metroid
dread but I can guarantee as a game that
I played and enjoyed it was the same
thing I just wasn't at home to record it
it happens and while it's really easy
for me to still keep up the podcasts
even when I'm remote it can be a little
bit harder to do
um a recording of a Nintendo game
because I don't always take my Elgato
recording stuff with me everywhere I go
but I especially don't take the switch
door I'll take the Switch I'll rarely
take the door next season said hey Alana
when can we hear you talk about all the
work you did on Ragnarok would you make
a video detailing what you did and what
it required huge fan and I know
accessibility is super important to you
why thank you so no
um and I've answered this so many times
I'm sure we'll keep answering it over
the next however many years I do not
intend to leave Santa Monica Studio
anytime soon so it's probably going to
keep happening I did talk about this at
length in the latest player watch listen
um but to explain why I won't talk about
what I do for a living I won't even
detail what my day-to-day is the most
Insight that you'll get to my job is on
the video game writing 101 podcast where
I do talk about it a lot more openly
than anywhere else and I think this is a
specific to Sony thing if I were working
in another Studio it probably wouldn't
be this way but that is where I work and
thus I want to be as respectful to
everybody I work with as possible
essentially So based basically it's very
uncommon for somebody who works in game
development to also have a YouTube
channel with 500 000 subscribers right
and as a result of my history of being
considered Media or press or a
journalist people still have that
perspective of me and people still call
me a journalist all the time despite it
not being something I've done for six
years I stopped in 2017. but that
perspective still exists
really weird position where working in
AAA game development is concerned where
if I'm going to talk about the stuff
that I do as a Dev I am basically
talking to a media Outlet about it even
though the media Outlet is myself
because of the size of the platform I
can't quite tweet the stuff that my
other colleagues can tweet as easily
because again my audience is akin to
media and if you ever want to talk to
Media to any media Outlet when you work
at a place like PlayStation you would
have to get that approved by PR so I had
a bunch of friends like ask me to do
podcasts Funhouse asked me if I could
play God of War Ragnarok with them all
of that stuff I was like this probably
isn't going to happen but let me ask and
they said no because I'm not on the list
of very very specific contained media
approved people who are chosen for very
specific reasons it makes perfect sense
why I'm not on that list it's very small
very purposeful list essentially the
reason I want to talk about what I do or
what I did and while I've been vague the
whole time is because I've been asked to
I have been very pointedly off to be
vague and it's been a very weird awkward
thing to navigate that's why the only
thing that I've spoken about doing
publicly at length is working on
accessibility for God of War Ragnarok
which I can still talk about to certain
extents I'm still cautious about but
it's mostly because yeah if I talk about
something and I give you a ton of detail
it is counted as me talking to Media
even though I myself am the media which
you need to be PR approved to do and my
stance is I care a lot more about my job
than I care about my YouTube channel
that has applied at every company I've
worked for and I just don't want to make
anyone's jobs harder so if I make a
YouTube video where I talk about
something the likelihood of it making
news headlines is pretty high that
doesn't necessarily apply for people who
tweet something or share something on
Instagram if they're also at the studio
but have a small following and I would
not want to do that to PR whatever
manager or any of the other people that
I work with because it just makes their
jobs more complicated if someone who is
outside of the approved media people is
talking to Media even if I myself am the
media I hope that makes sense there are
a couple of other layers to it like I'm
in a really unique position where I'm
still allowed to make content a lot of
people at AAA Studios aren't allowed to
do podcasts without being media approved
at all no matter the topic and so I
don't want to screw that up I don't want
to
overstep or over share and make a
mistake and then have it be a headline
and cause issues for PR and then have
them say this is why nobody's allowed to
do this in theory if I can keep doing
this without making it difficult for the
people I work with in any way then I
hope that more people who work in game
development will also be allowed to make
a little bit more content as long as
they excise the same amount of caution
as me the third thing is that I want to
be very very careful
and this is a really tough thing for me
to do that I've been just trying my best
to do I have the most followers of
anybody at the studio and that means
that I can accidentally make myself a
spokesperson and I shouldn't be a
spokesperson because I have no more role
at the studio than anyone else on my
level people like Corey and Eric and
again the approved media spokespersons
spokespeople should be the spokespeople
so I I am trying to balance being really
supportive and talking about how proud I
am and also sharing it with an audience
in a way that I think is helpful because
it humanizes game developers you know me
a lot of people have been following me
for like 10 years and watched my whole
career it is really helpful for me to
talk about how I got to where I am for
anyone else who also might be interested
but I also really don't want to take the
spotlight or the conversation away from
everybody else at the studio which is
hundreds of people so I'm trying to play
this this careful game of like I want to
be supportive I want to tell everyone
how proud I am to work there and how
proud I am of all the teams that I work
with and how much I love working there
but I also don't want people to look at
me as a default for speaking about Santa
Monica Studio or associate the studio
with me I would prefer to remain to just
a regular old little employee and that's
part of why I've been weird about how
I'm timing any God of War Ragnarok
uploads the latest episode of playwatch
listen which is me live reacting to
seeing the review scores which was a
really fun thing to record I
intentionally published late because I
wanted PR2 have approved my phrasing of
how I talked about the way that I worked
on the game and then I waited to upload
my yonar Edition Unboxing because I
wanted to make sure other YouTubers did
it first and then I'm still planning to
upload me playing the first hour of the
game on PS5 but I wanted to wait even
longer to do that so there isn't like an
association in people's heads where they
go if I want content about Sony Santa
Monica Studio it's a lot of PS she works
there she's the one to go to no go to
the at Sony Santa Monica Twitter account
Instagram account go to Corey go to the
people who are supposed to be that not
me so yeah it's just a big old game of
trying to be super respectful to the
people that I work with trying not to
take a spotlight away while also
enthusing and being very proud and
supportive and trying not to mess
anything up for anyone else who does
podcasts or whatever because if I screw
it up it'll be very public and people
will find out very quickly and that we
could hurt everybody else who comes
after me who would ever want to stream
or make podcasts or whatever so I hope
that makes sense and answer is this
question thoroughly I've seen people
like suggest that I'm being Coy for some
sort of clout reason and no it's
actually just that it's very complicated
and hard and so often when I talk about
stuff I have to stop and really just
think about it because I it's so many
things that I'm being considerate of so
that's effectively why I won't talk
about my job you know if I were ever
going to detail all the stuff that I've
done or what I did on Ragnarok what I've
been doing as a video game writer for
the last two years in general it would
probably need to be on something
somebody approved or Sony would have to
prove me as a media spokesperson to do
those things which it doesn't make any
sense to them to do because why why me
and not any of the other writers why me
and not just talk to Corey or Eric or
somebody way more senior than me one of
our leads right it wouldn't it would be
weird it would be a weird thing to do
and I think that's probably part of why
I started the video again writing
one-on-one podcast was so that it can
still give people a lot of insight
through other writers and through some
of the the more vague things I say on
there and maybe one day weigh in the
future sure I'll be able to talk about
stuff more but for now I'm just trying
to be respectful and easy to work with
and respect my team and understand the
weirdness of who I am in relation to AAA
game development that's it I'm sorry if
you find it frustrating but know that I
love my job
and and to all the people who are really
on it about how they think that I only
write side quests or lore or item
descriptions that that is nonsense okay
just that one I'll tell you I have just
as much say as any of the other writers
nonsense and most of the work I did on
Ragnarok even though obviously again I
have been a writer in studio velocities
was accessibility and I'm so so so proud
of that game for accessibility I'm so
proud of it it's incredible a very big
shout out to that team which is made up
of Mila Sam Kiyomi Katie and Kathleen
incredible people who I think did a very
good job so yeah maybe one day in the
future for now just watch video game
writing 101 it'll give you all that
information anyway and I understand why
people are curious it doesn't bother me
that people keep asking questions I get
that and I know that this video isn't
going to stop them from coming but know
that I'm just trying to be respectful to
my workplace which has to be more
important to me than YouTube comments
that's just just the reality of life
my job is super important if I lost
YouTube tomorrow that would be okay I
lost my job because I gave out too much
information about something on YouTube
or I made something difficult for
marketing or PR I would be devastated so
we play it safe it is time to talk about
keeps keeps is a subscription service
that helps men keep their hair and of
course there's no magic cure for
boldness but you can prevent hair loss
from happening in the first place the
early you take action the more hair
you'll keep of course this is only if
this is something that you are concerned
about or insecure about and I do feel
like it's helpful for people to know
there are options so as for how keeps
Works they offer clinically proven
treatments to combat the symptoms of
hair loss they are FDA approved provider
recommended and are delivered straight
to customers doors you'll get your daily
supply of treatment arriving every three
months and at half the cost of a
Pharmacy Plus of course all treatment
plans are personalized and recommended
by a licensed medical provider which is
super important then step three is to
just take action track your progress and
get support along the way keeps
treatment plans come with a year of
unlimited on-demand access to a
dedicated medical provider and there are
proven results most keeps customers
notice results within six months of
starting treatment so keeps has you
covet with clinically proven
research-backed treatments to stop hair
loss and improve hair growth so whether
you're looking to prevent hair loss
stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair you have keeps
has you covered hair loss stops with
keeps to get 50 off your first order go
to keeps.com alone appears or click the
link in the description that's
k-e-e-p-s.com a lot of puce S3 prototype
said hey Alana keep up the great work
every video slash podcast is somewhat
something different and I'm here for all
of them thank you how is visiting the G4
offices before they closed shop bonus if
you feel so inclined what is your
opinion on the whole situation with G4
great question I have many opinions I
have said them on stream before but not
on YouTube I don't think so yeah I
visited G4 twice before they shut down
uh one was that they were trying to get
me to have a recurring spot on X-Play
I I'm pretty sure X-Play the other one
was that I was a guest on the the
lowdown I don't know what the shows are
called I'm sorry that's probably very
disrespectful but I don't know what
they're called I was a guest on Usher
that was part of attack of the show I
think and the first one which was
talking to them about xplayer came
before talking to them about
doing the podcast as a guest
um so then when they asked me about
xplay I was like well I would do this if
you can work around my hours and it
doesn't have to cut into my work hours
at all obviously and mostly because I
liked the oh there he goes
Spencer just he likes sleeping in the
bathtub so that's where he goes just
helps himself to it for xplay I said I
would do it
um yeah if they could work around my
work I was obviously my job is priority
for everything but it was more because I
really liked the people I really I loved
Gerard and would have been so happy to
work with him and it would have been fun
they also had the opportunity for me to
create cool stuff like I would have
loved for the accessibility Awards to be
something that G4 helped me with but I
also in that meeting with them expressed
my concerns with G4 as a network that I
had from the very beginning and was
pretty blunt and shocked that I didn't
offend them because apparently they
still liked me somehow because I like I
said I was very blunt about it so how
was visiting the G4 offices that place
is cool and amazing and huge
unnecessarily huge I've worked at IGN
I've worked at Rooster Teeth two very
big production houses GFR was so much
bigger than both of those and so much
more expensive than both of those it was
insane the second patio question which
is what is your opinion on the whole
situation with G4 I think the downfall
was inevitable
um and I felt that very early on I did
not see a world in which it worked and
again all love and respect to so many
people I love who worked there and the
layoffs obviously suck I just didn't see
how it had
value that would equate with the cost I
do not see what value something like ven
who I was also approached to work with
and declined because their contracts
were insane so glad I didn't do that
that was terrible or G4 I don't
understand what they offer to an
audience
that the audiences can't get
faster and in a more again relatable
human way on YouTube or twitch from an
individual Creator I just don't
understand the point so when I was
talking to them about that I was like
okay well what you have here is unique
you have money of a set you have
production and a scale of which majority
of creators don't have access to what
are you doing with that that's different
and as far as I could tell when I looked
at all that content the answer to that
was nothing
um and they didn't really give me a
solid answer to that other than
understanding what I was expressing
which is you should be taking advantage
of all of this stuff and not just making
the same content that I can make on my
couch with an iPhone but I don't think
they were they weren't making anything
that anyone couldn't make elsewhere thus
there is no demand for that kind of
content and it can't justify its cost if
you want to watch game reviews you can
watch somebody do it from home you're
going to watch somebody like donkey
Skillet and while there are still teams
who have Studios who make reviews they
generally just don't get anywhere near
as many views as the individual creators
do again I think that's not the last
Escape of content right now so yeah the
whole situation to me seems like a bunch
of really excellent people got recruited
and they had an incredibly cool setup it
was so cool and I'm really bummed that
that was very good creative people never
really had a chance to be effectively
creative together because again just
from my perspective
it seems like they were thrown into
something that was like G4 you'll watch
it because you know the name I never
watched G4 and I've been gaming since I
was like five [ __ ] years old I never
had any need for that content marketing
something on Nostalgia isn't good enough
when most people aren't going to invest
hours and hours and hours and hours
enough to support a business based on
Nostalgia and then whenever things
weren't working or like they realized
that maybe that Nostalgia play wasn't
getting immediately a million views they
would just shift very quickly to
whatever another Trend was and shift
very quickly to another Trend and so
they never actually got views anywhere
from anything that was really
um unusual or creative I think God of
work which um Gerard put together
was really cool and very unique and an
example of G4 doing something that only
G4 could do but for the most part they
seemed like they were scrambling to act
like every other YouTuber but with a
massive team and a massive office that
they just couldn't support and it does
seem like part of that is an
organizational fault and again them
relying way too much on G4 but I think
for the most part as I keep saying I
just don't think that content has any
Demand right now people want to watch
individual creators where past YouTube
groups I don't even think there's a
future for Rooster Teeth anymore I think
the content has shifted to very reality
TV style watching your five favorite
twitch streamers and then occasionally
they come together to do something
together and that's the big event but
otherwise you will watch them all
individually that's where we're at I
think outside of maybe groups of like
two the gaming content landscape of
groups is just done there are of course
exceptions but um unless you have some
really really unique pitch which G4 did
not
I don't think they ever stood a chance
and I felt like that from the very
beginning and again it's a bummer
because I think their constant
scrambling meant that nobody was even
really given the opportunity to use
those resources because they like were
so worried about immediate views I do
also want to add to that notion that
people think that G4 shut down because
of frost well I've spoken about the
frost situation before this is a person
that I don't know but I found their uh
some of the stuff that they had said
um to be very disagreeable and not
necessarily somebody that I would think
that I would want to watch as a gaming
host I remember seeing her say um
PlayStation was dead in the water this
year and somebody who worked on a
PlayStation game this year that people
seem to really like when that happened I
was like Wow harsh she also Then
followed up and tweeted when we
announced the release date and said
something along the lines of like all
this release date means is that these
people are crunching and the game's not
going to be good like it was like I was
like what an unnecessary thing to say
what it just what what why what a
negative ass thing to say my God however
I stand by what I said which is the
people who went and her asked her
because they didn't like a I don't Vibe
with you at all I didn't like some chefs
she said I still don't know her at no
point did I ever feel the need to harass
her okay I stand by that just [ __ ]
ignore people you don't like my point is
anyone who thinks that G4
um failed because of frost I think
doesn't understand business G4 was
always going to fail because their
expenses were too high and they had no
demand they were not providing any
content that was in demand because
everybody else could do it faster
and more personally which is the
appealing content right now it was
basically going to fail regardless in my
opinion a single woman is not capable of
taking down a Comcast supported company
there is no way they never got the views
they were never going to it's
a bummer
I wish it could have worked out for them
differently a lot of really good people
there but it is what it is depressed
Tuttle said as someone who's always
dreamed of being in the video game
industry and loves writing what would be
a good way to try and get into the
industry is there something that would
be a good major in college or other
avenues that would be helpful is it also
as unstable as seems from the outside
looking in I hear horror stories about
Mass layoffs and people getting sick
from the work but it's something that
just seems fulfilling from an autistic
standpoint I'm sure I've answered this a
million times but I'm happy to answer it
again because people always ask and so
why not uh what I did to get into the
games industry is do a lot of writing
for free and I did this at both the
different kinds of writing jobs that I
have had being journalism and now
fiction I didn't mean to give you the
thing but I'm sorry about that I
volunteered in a lot of cases
um I am a person who hustles very hard
and hustling works so when I was trying
to get into the journalism side I went
to events met people got business cards
and then pitched them on features and
you do have to know how to pitch a
feature That's Unique that is a thing
that you have to learn that's how I
started getting work there as well as
found a bunch of local websites
and asked if I could write for free just
to get a portfolio and to
sort of understand the world that I was
so desperately trying to get into I did
the same thing
for video game writing is in literally
writing video games I did a bunch of
game jams under a fake name
intentionally so people didn't know who
I was but two of them I even used a
different accent
you won't have to worry about that
probably so I did game jams and
um I also you know using the connections
that I had from my time in the industry
already reached out to game studios and
asked if I could
um
sit in on their writer's rooms and sign
an NDA and then contributed to some
games I also
some games
literally found things on Kickstarter
and asked if they needed writers so it
was a lot of like I need this experience
where can I get this experience let me
build a portfolio of course a big part
of it is that I've also always just been
a writer so when it came to giving my
samples for Santa Monica Studio I
submitted I'm pretty sure
um a scene from a screenplay I submitted
a short story and I submitted some game
writing script version that I had done
for another project so I had a bunch of
stuff to submit I think I may have even
submitted a character sheet which is
obviously something that's pretty
important it might approached at any job
as a very career orientated person
frankly it's too much is that I try to
make myself as employable as possible so
yes I went to University and I studied a
degree of mass communication majoring in
journalism and entertainment writing
which obviously I use the journalism
part and I'm now using the entertainment
writing part but I also it's a thing
that people sometimes criticize me for
is like the suggestion that I only got a
job because I'm popular I have
absolutely no doubt that having a
following and knowing people helps so
try and do that work on that too so
start networking go to events start
sharing opinions on Twitter meet people
who are in the same field as you that
you can network with do everything you
possibly can to stand out from everybody
else who would be applying for the same
jobs because they are very competitive
and again for me I know a lot of people
don't like it and that's totally fair it
was a lot of volunteer writing
um and that's that is pretty much it
volunteer meet people show people your
work tell people you want jobs that is
the path and it has worked for me
beautifully I have accomplished
everything I wanted to and I am already
working on the next goal which I think
is going to take a bit longer but I
think I'll get there too because of
doing the same [ __ ] thing to do the
work meet people think about things
that'll make you
um an asset to a company and obtain
those skills I do not think college is
required though I imagine it helped me
in the same kind of way it helped me
stand out from other people who didn't
study at University but I don't think
that you need to at all and I definitely
work with people who uh happen the other
question is is it as unstable as it
seems from the outside looking in I mean
here's another thing I get criticized
about sometimes people make jokes about
how I can't keep a job for more than six
months which is very weird because
um I've never had a job for less than
two years but it is certainly true of
video game writing specifically that you
will jump around a lot I was talking to
my colleagues about it the other day and
most of them have not worked at a single
place for three years
um so it is unstable yes people usually
leave projects
and join other projects for a myriad of
reasons it is not something that a lot
of people tend to work
um in any or for any given company as a
writer for a long period of time that is
I think just a reality of being a writer
professionally you are going to want to
write about different things under
different circumstances
and Chase what is best for you and I
think that that is healthy but if you
are a person who thrives on stability it
is not something that I think would be
easy to pursue for Mass layoffs and
people getting sick from work I I don't
feel as confident speaking about that to
be honest uh just because I have not
been laid off but I've also well I've
probably gotten sick from work yeah that
probably that's happened a few times and
I will keep doing it don't ask me about
those questions
because I am unfortunately a person who
will throw everything at work until I am
bleeding on the ground and it's not
healthy and I would not suggest it for
anybody but yeah really is that simple
you gotta hustle and again sorry if
you've heard me answer that question a
million times
um but I don't remember which videos
I've spoken about it in so have another
one
I think that's pretty much it uh
here's a good one Tyrell Tomlinson said
what if God of War Ragnarok has online
multiplayer like Call of Duty with some
micro transactions and a battle pass are
you going to buy that no no I would not
buy that
alrighty and Moana thank you all for
watching like I said leave any questions
for the next one below and I will get to
them I will see you guys next time bye